[Music]
what got you so much into zombies did
you watch a lot of zombie films growing
up I was I was 13 it was 1985 you know
when you're 13 you have one goal when
you're a boy is to see boobies yes and
you know kids today don't understand
they get hardcore porn on their phones
it's I talk about this all the time to
my son you don't get it oh you know we
like grew up during the Depression the
bubi depression yes there were no
breasts
we were porns greatest generation
exactly 30 killed we were you would have
to search you'd have to search yes you
had to wait in front of cable TV like a
sniper hoping that maybe police academy
or stripes would come on and there'd be
a shower scene for no reason right and
there was no way to record it no so you
just had to see it and try and sketch it
that was okay I know what they're round
got it one night I'm watching and
finally I see a woman oh my god and
she's awesome from way down yeah I
thought ah there is a god right you saw
a full naked life full naked woman I
said they do exist and then I realized
unfortunately I had accidentally watched
an Italian cannibal zombie movie oh
where they had edited in I think real
cannibal footage right right you know
when you're 13 and the biggest problem
is hair growing in weird places that
traumatizes you yes I was legitimately
scared of zombies right right and that
but that worked for you you got you you
it's it brought the book remember years
ago and y2k was coming out and people
were stocking up and I went looking for
something that would help me survive a
zombie attack and nobody written that
book right no they were all having a
life so I thought those idiots oh I
don't have that problem yeah
you're not burdened no I will I have two
wonderful god-given talents at that
point I had a OCD right and unemployment
you combine ice incredible powers and I
got Zombie Survival Guide